[Music]
ah
well
hope folks are doing well
hope you can see me hope you can hear me
and according to steven you can in fact
do
both hey
everybody i hope that your day is going
smoother than mine it
ah this month like in some ways has gone
okay but in other ways it's been like
really
um
that said i'm coming off of
having had a very lovely weekend with
liz away which is something i think we
both needed
um to uh to just you know pull a quote
from
that premiere episode of uh
of she-hulk you know it's it's a good
time and a bad
in a bad time
so
um but yeah i i hope um
huh i hope folks are doing okay i like i
i don't i don't want to make it sound
like things are horrible i'm just kind
of like exhausted
in what feels like a very unproductive
way that's just kind of where i'm at
after the day
you meet your eight year old self you're
only allowed to say three words what do
you say
it'll be all right
that's what i say
i just gotta let go from my job at
subway oh jamie i am
really sorry to hear that
a best of luck in
in finding something else
uh
oh jeez carol when you're right i do
have a super chat right out the gate
which i suppose
gives me a good reason to discuss uh the
the chat and how things work around here
in case anyone needs a reminder or is
new so
um i do try and keep up with the chat as
best as i can but the only thing that is
going to guarantee that i see your
comment or question is either to do it
as a super chat or
if you are a supporter on patreon and in
the council of geeks discord there was a
channel for you to post your questions
however um
that the cutoff time for that was the
actual start of the stream so those had
to be in already but if you're not
already supporting me on the patreon you
could do that and be prepared to uh ask
questions that way
at the next live stream but in the
meantime uh super chat gets you not only
guarantee that i will read your comment
or question and respond to it but also
gets you
a heart from me in appreciation so from
john vinyls if amphibia ever becomes a
broadway musical you should play general
union i need to learn her whole
spiel
like i i i
i i don't ever memorize i am general
union
did scourge of the
slayer of the something i gotta learn i
gotta learn that
i could bug my kid with it i think that
i need to learn it for that reason alone
watch your review of sandman earlier
today the bonus episode or the the full
one that's up for the patreon supporters
uh
oh michael anderson doyle thank you very
much member for 10 months thank you
kindly seven months not a dull moment to
be had thank you vera well thank you
love your videos thank you riley i
appreciate that
can't stay long but everyone take care
of yourselves
uh and each other oh
thank you emily sorry you can't stay but
it was good to see you
how am i i'm i'm just kind of tired
that's just kind of what the day's been
our philosophy
is that is an interesting uh
uh
chat name so thank you very much for the
super chat for whatever it's worth
consider me one african-american
individual who takes no issue with you
dressing as 14.
i appreciate that it seems to be like
based off the um
response i got to that video where i was
wondering that question
um there seems to be a lot less
hostility to the idea then i think i had
feared i still don't like know for
certain how i'll feel i think honestly
i think a lot of it might have to do
with what
um
shirigatwa's
outfit ends up being and what i mean by
that is like
i'm not sure as much as i love
um joe martin's outfit as a fugitive
doctor i'm not sure i'd ever feel
totally comfortable dressing that
knowing that like
the patterns that are in the the shirt
and like in the the cuffs coming out of
the sleeves
are specifically um
africa traditional african patterns
knowing that i'm not sure i'd be
comfortable cosplaying as that doctor so
if they end up bringing those kinds of
elements into shooty gaucho's doctor
into the 14th doctor
that might be where i'm like but if
those aren't there i'll probably get
over it but we'll see we will see what
we ended up getting
got a new cat her name is cleo that's a
popular cat name she says hello she's a
big fan of your work oh thank you cleo
much appreciated i ended up doing three
culture questions because i was late and
i had to go with whatever would stop my
head it's not meant to pestering you to
get the review out i am i'm in the home
stretch on that one uh 255 a.d i i am
i do expect i will have the review out
this month it'll be
it'll be down to the wire but i'm almost
done with that book so
by the way i know you already did a
video on celeste but the creator is
trans and they confirm that madeleine
the main character is also trans which
in my opinion makes the game a hundred
times better
i feel like i'd have to replay it again
with that in mind to decide
if that alters my overall opinion of it
it might it couldn't hurt like i enjoyed
the game mechanically the theming to me
didn't it didn't land with me as well as
i know it lands with a lot of people and
i don't think it's because the theme is
bad it's just because from
my experiences both personally and those
of people who matter to me the way that
it chose to depict what it was doing
didn't quite land right
did i watch the series premiere of house
of the dragon not yet
um i'm probably gonna end up watching
that well
i don't know i might watch that after
the stream or i might watch that in the
morning it'll probably be one of the two
so most likely a review for that out
tomorrow
uh now that you're a full season into
babylon 5 do you have any thoughts
uh on if that reboot by jms is trying to
get off the ground is a good idea um
i'm i don't
i don't know so like here's the thing
there's a lot about
babylon 5 that you know is dated
obviously the visuals certainly some of
the
uh perspectives and characterizations
garibaldi comes
very readily to mind
um
and
some of that like i would like to see
tweaked and there is an argument to be
made that it's worth it just to bring
the same core story
up to date with those adjustments for a
new audience and like
i'm not going to say there's no value in
that but that's
for me that's not enough to have it be
worth a reboot
and i don't know how you would like do a
massive
i mean like we'll see maybe i'll have a
different opinion as i get further into
it i don't know how you do a massive
upheaval in its component parts or it's
plotting and still have it be babylon 5.
that's kind of my concern there i'm now
five episodes into both buffy season
four and angel season one
both are a little rough uh rowan buffy
season four actually has some phenomenal
individual episodes the season as a
whole is rough and angel season one it's
it's kind of struggling to find its
footing in that first season
also when the development team started
working on celeste there was one trans
developer but when they finished making
celeste three of them were trans well uh
correction jamie they were all always
trans
by the time they had three who were out
as trans
but i get i get what you mean
thoughts on james somerton's new video
on owl house also does your kid hate
general union if so why oh she doesn't
hate general union i just like quoting
stuff from shows and it just as a way to
bug her i don't know james summerton i
don't know who that is so
i have no thoughts on
their new owl house video because i've
no clue who that is
um do you read any online webcomics i
haven't in a while
i
i i used to i used to read um
sluggy freelance i don't even know if
it's still going
but um
yeah i like that comic a lot
every reaction slash review of house of
dragon i've seen starts with oh it's not
terrible thank god let's see like here's
the thing and i'll probably do a review
of the premiere but like i don't know if
it's something i'll stick with not in
terms of watching it but in terms of
reviewing it because
and
rationally like i know i know
and i understand that
um this is based off material that is
finished unlike the main book series
this is based off of fire and blood or
whatever it was that is a finnish thing
so they have the whole thing to work on
and the two guys who completely
destroyed the end of game of thrones are
not involved like intellectually i know
all that
but i don't know if i'm gonna trust that
a game of thrones related tv series even
if it starts out good will stay good
i just don't know if i can trust that
and maybe that's unfair because it's
only going up one show and this as i
said as a different creative team but
like
what what the heck else am i gonna base
it off of other than the last show
i don't know
i don't know we'll see we'll see what i
think maybe maybe it'll wrap me into it
enough that i'll get over it we'll see
any favorite classic doctor who
companions yeah ace and jamie would be
the big ones i like tegan too
do you have a comic collection i do not
a very big one i only have one long box
um worth of stuff and most of it is
painfully 90s because that's when i was
actually buying loose issues i haven't
bought a comic in
decades i don't remember the last time i
bought a single issue of a comic
uh it's been quite a while
what was your overall take on babylon 5
series 1 uh for me it's interesting as
so many things develop especially londo
and jakar except for garibaldi and the
dock who are still we're still asshats
um it was interesting like london londo
kind of came fully formed i'm actually
not sure how much he developed over that
first season jacquard did that was
interesting to see
yeah garibaldi
there were a certain circumstances and
certain types of stories
or roles within a story
that um they give garibaldi where he
works
but
my overall takeaway is wow this guy is
such a freaking cop and i do not mean
that as a compliment
it's oh it's rough sometimes but um
but then there's franklin who
oh
sure
have i seen young sheldon no
someone would have to pay me to watch
young sheldon
um
thoughts on interact
interactive fiction games that aren't
visual novels so what you mean like uh
the sort of thing telltale did
um i actually never really played too
much of those they seemed okay
did death of superman really ruin death
in comics doesn't the blame belong to
jean grey's resurrection in 86 because
that that is undoing a classic death um
so all right couple of things about
superman
and the death and return of superman
so
it is an oversimplification
to say that the death and return of
superman ruined death in comics in the
same way that it is an
oversimplification
to say that the dark age of comics came
about because of the release of the dark
knight returns in watchmen
if
the things were happening anyways it's
easy to point to these specific works as
being a demarcation point but in reality
these oh well supreme omega sorry i
forgot to give you a heart there um but
these specific works
were the embodiments of something that
was already happening
so to lay the blame on these works
themselves is an oversimplification
although they are helpful as kind of a
marker of what was going on at the time
i don't think the comparison to jean
grey
is
fair though
because the first is she was a member of
a team and as an individual her
life or death didn't mean as much as
someone like superman like the whole
idea of killing superman is like if
you're not gonna commit to it why are
you doing it
whereas jean grey just doesn't carry
that kind of weight and also like
she played
her character was called phoenix
are we that shocked that a character
named after a mythological creature that
dies and rises from its own ashes
came back to life
you know what i mean
um so i don't i don't think that
comparison uh works super well but like
the short version is that no the death
of sue the death of return of superman
did not break death in comics but
it works as marking as a bullet point of
something that was starting to go on
anyways
do i own any vinyl
um
so
yes but okay
what i own on vinyl are
things like disney records
from when i was from when i was a kid
like i have
actually this was my mother's originally
i think i have like the uh the album for
uh the haunted mansion
um and i think i still have the jungle
book soundtrack on vinyl
oh dear
you've mentioned not caring for rick and
morty any thoughts on community only
seen it recently myself recently i think
it referred to
rick and the abused teenager i only ever
saw the first episode of community and i
just never
i just that was like close to when it
was airing and i just didn't get hooked
in i haven't watched enough episodes of
community to actually have an opinion
on it
also with regards to the review if it
was early september that'd be fine
because they come out during my holiday
vacation like the accession one did
we'll see where it lands uh the lake
where dirty dancing was filmed sadly
dried up due to a drought
it and many others i've heard rumors of
disney doing a firefly series but with
different characters different time and
timeline any thoughts on the idea well
given that
um
given that joss whedon is oh hey meg
hey
i'm glad you stopped in it's good to see
you uh sorry let me get
let me get back to the question oh and
it's from tidbit i didn't even notice
that hi tidbit thank you for stopping in
um so
here's the thing i i don't think we
would ever expect disney anytime soon if
ever to employ joss whedon given the
kinds of on-set behavior and the general
tarnishing of his image that has gone on
they won't hire him so
and also for similar reasons they would
never
bring in um adam baldwin so that's you
know the creator and one of the
significant significant characters it's
already already like
and i would say even more so than buffy
firefly really kind of was
whedon's
baby i mean like buffy became more
collaborative as it went along and angel
arguably
um was as dependent on some of the other
co-creators like uh greenwald as it was
on whedon firefly really kind of was his
thing so if you're going to
revive the series or reboot the series
or
whatever
in the absence of the original creator
it's probably better
to do it with different characters
maybe in a different point in the
timeline different setting different
something so that it
basically you commit to bringing back
the feel and the flavor but not the plot
and the characters now does that mean
it'll be good no doesn't mean fans will
accept it hell no but creatively i think
that's a better idea considering the
creative assets that they basically
can't really use just for image issue
reasons
ah
so uh we've got some more super chats
john vinyls thank you once again my
friend
why do you think it's easier for people
to still enjoy buffy despite whedon
turning out to be a not great person
than those wizard books well
uh a couple of reasons
like the core thing to remember
um
between someone like
joss whedon and someone like jk rowling
is the problem with him
were things that he did
and
rightly or wrongly it is easier to
disassociate
someone's actions from their creative
work
jk rowling the people who dislike her
their problem is what she believes
and it is much harder
to separate what one believes
from their creative work in addition to
the fact that
joss whedon basically as long as he's
never handed the keys to a big budget on
a for a film or a tv show again
doesn't really have on his own the
ability to keep doing what he was doing
because what he was largely accused of
um at least substantively was
dictatorial and toxic onset behavior so
as long as he's not in control of a set
he can't keep doing it jk rowling
continues to voice her incredibly
harmful beliefs about trans people so
she is continuing to do active harm
whereas whedon
while i'm this is not a defense of the
man
he kind of can't do much more damage
right now unless somebody gives them the
authority to do so and as i said earlier
nobody really seems to want to do that
so
i think because of those reasons it
makes it easier to detach the problems
with him because he's not
currently being an active problem
and also it was an issue an act of
actions whereas rowling it's a thing of
beliefs which are more likely to seep
into the original work
and it's something she is continuing to
do
i think those are the two major
differences because then it largely
comes down to whether or not whedon's
actions
set off your own personal
factor so hard that like you just can't
deal with his work regardless but if it
doesn't quite hit that level for you
then you know there's still some
enjoyment to be had i haven't tried
revisiting weed and stuff yet i mean
aside from avengers sort of for the for
the body count but anyways
um
do you watch any youtube animator of so
who i watch illibation
um i think that's the main one
ten
that's fun to say
stomp
thank you very much for the super chat
hey vera not sure if i asked you this
before but do you have a favorite x-men
character besides wolverine yeah
mystique
and i know she's usually a villain but
that's still my answer
she's been a
good-ish guy sometimes
but if you want backups uh kitty pride
and uh
and kurt
kurtz wagner
the incredible night crawler would be
the other ones
uh
where did i leave off
um
i've been on a big sandman kick recently
so i was curious if you've read the
lucifer comics and or could recommend
them i never did read those comics so i
actually cannot give an opinion on those
uh house of the dragon is fictional
history of westeros not a prose novel
that makes me wonder if the show writer
was closer to creating historical
fiction than adapting a novel that's an
interesting perspective did you own any
laserdisc no
those things were so expensive you crazy
uh
abc is airing a special tonight about
the bran about the brandy cinderella
at eight that i will be watching i keep
forgetting that was a thing
um
let's see if you were to choose what is
your favorite episode of doctor who
classic or new my answer
my answer to that tends to vary
depending on when you ask me i think
it's still the dr falls it has been
heaven sent before
uh
i mean my favorite classic is
city of death and i don't usually tend
to compare classic to new
i don't know
those are that's like your uh your top
three contenders
ah
where did i leave off here ah i so much
respect uh for both charisma carpenter
and elijah dushku for all the crap
they've both been through even outside
of wheat and stuff yep
yep agreed
kind of cliche question favorite
superheroes of all time
i'm still partial to spider-man
oh oh and miguel o'hare is the best
spider-man don't at me
joss whedon putting the dick in dick
tutorial yep that that fits meg
let's see will you ever touch something
like pure flix or kirk cameron's new
films not unless somebody pays me
like there's there's our there are whole
swaths of things that like
no
somebody would have to commission me
someone would have to pay me money
that's the only way
i remember seeing rocky horror on
laserdisc it was 100
at the time yeah
yeah i know you need to realize also
vhs's weren't that cheap either
like in the 80s uh even into the early
90s but definitely in the 80s they were
like
20 25 bucks a piece and that was in 80s
money that's not adjusted for inflation
uh have you read any of the doctor who
comics from titan comics i have somebody
sent me a collection i think fourth
doctor
stuff which i haven't read i need to
there's a lot
there's lots of stuff people have sent
me
be they movies or stuff to read that i
have not gotten to and i feel bad and i
need to
how much do i have to pay you to do
stuff depends on what it is a black
cover if you check out the patreon you
will see uh pricing for commissioning me
to review something like
a movie or a book or a few episodes of a
tv show or a full season of a tv show it
price goes up depending on the size of
the project
when you were answered that that do you
own any vinyl question
like i said what on my kitchen floor
um no what i could is what i could have
said uh was i could have brought up the
vinyl dress i used to have
at that that i don't have anymore
pure flakes is a strange rabbit hole to
fall down better youtubers than me have
gone down that rabbit hole so
you know power to them
but i i think that's uh that's a pass
for me oh hey bookworm good to see you
oh golly pure flicks if i ever get out
of this financial fix i will defo
commission you to review a pure flix
flick oh dear
just to see
the expression on your face and hear the
snark
i have been commissioned to hate watch
stuff before it happens on occasion
uh when will the next mcu body count
come out i like those uh next month tail
end of next month it will be captain
america body count
uh speaking of both pure flix and buffy
okay aerobia scott aka jenny calendar is
in unplanned as the evil head of planned
parenthood
that's a shame
why do i not try to pirate content um
you know it's funny because um
i uh
i'm kind of gonna be addressing that in
uh
in a video
um
next month
but um
at this point my reason for not pirating
has changed over time at this point i
mainly don't pirate because
i have very bad luck stepping outside of
the standard use of technologies
i have very bad luck with
um
third-party apps i have very bad luck
with mods i have very bad luck with
torrents i have very and anything that
that isn't just plug and play and
anything that i need to do a workaround
or i need to connect two things or i
need to do this kind of backdoor kind of
thing to get i just have very bad luck
with and i'm frankly paranoia paranoia
is why i don't pirate at this point i
have
no sense of moral superiority about
pirating and especially at this point
given what is going on
as digital ownership becomes a more and
more ephemeral if not irrelevant concept
i i'm not judging people who pirate
peter venkman was originally going to be
played by john belushi before he died of
combined drug intoxication i know that
ms wicked wolf that's my favorite movie
yes i know the trivia for ghostbusters
i'm aware
uh what do you do when you get
commissioned to review stuff of
streaming services you don't own
um that actually has come up
very rarely um
i think it's only
i think it's only actually come up
once
so far
um
because well like a lot of the stuff i
can like i can rent for two bucks on
amazon prime and
yeah that's fine i accept that as a as a
cost of acquiring the product um i think
the only time it came up was
one of the early reviews
uh somebody commissioned me to review
the first season of titans
and
i didn't have because it wasn't even hbo
max at the time it was on
the dc universe app
now
i'm not going to say who it was but that
commission that person who commissioned
me
they pirated the episodes and made them
available to me in a way that i was
comfortable with so um
they sorted that for me
uh but yeah it largely hasn't come up
because really like
there's a number of services i don't
have
but
the
the kind of stuff that i review is
covered by most of the stuff that i have
and and i've gotten by okay with uh
with it so far
uh have you ever heard or seen the works
of derek savage creator of cool caddies
quite the individual i
feel like i've seen that name but i'm
not familiar
which doctor would you say you've seen
the most work of outside of doctor who
if any uh probably tenant
uh
yeah
well either tenant or recklesston it
would be one of the two
yeah
i might have asked this before
which doctor would be most likely to
save the porn industry and why is it 12.
see 12 would just install an auto
scrubbing
um extension on everybody's browser to
get rid of their browser history and
then just let everybody run wild that's
why
ah
our philosophy is thank you kindly for
the super chat you mentioned that you
don't follow or watch avatar the last
airbender would you ever get into it
it's known for legendary character
development morals for kids and adults
okay this hasn't come up in a while
i've seen the first two seasons
so it's not like i haven't tried
and i don't dislike it i don't think
it's bad
the problem is for me as a viewer is
i can readily acknowledge that if i had
watched it when it was airing i probably
would think much more highly of it than
i currently do
the problem is for me going back and
watching it now
i've seen the shows
that took what it did and ran further
with it that took what it showed
these kinds of cartoons serialized
things can be and did
more with them i've seen infinity train
i've seen shira and the princesses of
power i've seen owl house i've seen
amphibia i've seen these things that
did that are built on the shoulders of
avatar the last airbender and i
acknowledge that and acknowledge its
importance
but going back to it
i mean it's a bit like trying to get
someone who's used to modern horror
movies to go back and watch
you know the bella lugosi dracula they
can maybe appreciate it for its
historical value but they're probably
not going to get into it to the same
level because
what they're accustomed to is everything
that came after
so i'm kind of in the same situation i
don't think i have nothing bad to say
about avatar the last airbender but i
also don't have the same level of praise
that everyone else has which is why
i stopped talking about i did one review
for the first season and i did not do a
review of the second and i do not intend
to do any further reviews on any media
related to it
for the simple reason that
i know that i don't and probably never
will
love it
the way other people do
but i'm not here trying to put a damper
on anybody's fun
i understand their importance but i'm
never going to feel that strongly about
them and i've had people get mad at me
simply for not loving something as much
as they love it and i don't like that
feeling especially when it's something i
actually think is good
so that's the main reason i don't talk
about it
supreme omega
thank you very much for the super chat
thoughts on dark knight returns i feel
it's dated elements of it are dated the
uh a lot of the social commentary stuff
is
pretty dated um so that's like a lot of
the cutaways to news footage and that
sort of stuff
i think the core story still holds up
pretty well and a lot of the art holds
up decently
i think i'm i'm not sure there's
anything that frank miller has ever done
that has aged well
but i think that's probably aged better
than most
ah
moving along
moving
along where did i leave off
um
[Music]
how do you feel about non-official
streaming sites like one two three
movies or whatever i tend to get
everything from them if you can ignore
the porn pop-ups you can watch most
stuff i'm not familiar with the site
like i haven't even like re-done a lot
of research into what sites
are or aren't safe for that kind of
thing just because again like
it the idea of trying to use them makes
me antsy in the first place
have you seen a rival if so what did you
think of it i've seen it i love it i own
it on blu-ray it's a great movie
i need i haven't watched that in a while
uh so there was a seinfeld effect going
on with your experience of avatar the
last airbender i guess i'm not sure i'm
familiar with that term
uh
when we get oh sorry
ten uh when we get the next avengers
film which characters would you like to
be on the team and do you think sam
wilson will be the leader
i expect he will definitely be there
whether or not he'll be the leader kind
of depends on who's still around because
we're we're a number of years out i i am
expecting them to load it up with the
younger characters
um
so i'm expecting them to
to load up
uh you know re-re-re williams trying to
say her name fast when i'm halfway
through my cup of water is
tricky
but i expect them to load up on riri
williams and on kamala khan
and um and some stuff like that other
than that i i don't know
because they they might also have done
fantastic four by then
so
depending on how they do reed richards
he could possibly be leadership material
i i don't know
i think i i suspect whatever is the next
avengers film part of that story might
be a little bit of the leadership vacuum
left behind by
not having either tony or cap
there
i suspect that like that
unclearness of who should be in charge
might end up being part of that story
that's just a guess though
oh i enjoyed the original dracula made
me realize how much the show dark
shadows was inspired by the story oh i
enjoyed the original dracula too but i
saw it when i was like nine
and i'm not saying let like you can't
get enjoyment out of the older stuff
that influenced the stuff that you love
but i don't think you can
fall in love with it the same way
or at least i can't
where's my jet pack thank you very much
for the super chat i've been enjoying
re-watching babylon 5 alongside you and
jesse first season is the weakest but
i'm glad you're getting more into the
story as it's as it developed i mean
like
everyone seems to say first season of
babylon 5 is the weakest and i'm not
even necessarily going to argue i won't
know for a while but i like as much fun
as i make of some aspects of it i do
that because that's how i get enjoyment
um
but i like i do think it's good
john vinyls once more thank you very
much i've been thinking about steven
schwartz's musicals a lot lately and
would love to see him do owl house
i'm not you're gonna have to tell me
something stephen schwartz has done
because i
i
have seen that name
but i don't
um i'm drawing a blank meg oh meg thank
you so much for the super chat is there
a story or genre you'd like to see
taikawatiti put his spin on for the big
screen ooh
ooh
that is that's an interesting question
okay so
my brain went somewhere that would
actually be a terrible idea
um but now but now it's stuck in my head
taika watiti directing the next james
bond movie is what is latching into my
head
um
i don't know if i have a more serious
answer than that
um
[Music]
trying to think uh i think i think i
just have to roll with that like that
like that's stuck in my head now that's
that's what that's what my brain has
decided it wants
uh
i'm so sad sylvester mccoy is going to
be at a local con but covets still
enough of a concern around here i can't
risk it
with my immunocompromised system yeah
i'm really sorry about that carowind it
really yeah
that um
that's
it sucks
like fact this stuff is still going on
it sucks what do you think of the boys i
feel like that comes up every other
stream
i don't watch the boys i don't like the
source material i don't like the
majority of garth ennis's work i think
the only time he did anything good was
on the punisher and even then it was
only good for a fairly limited amount of
time for welcome back frank and bourne
and then he went off the rails like he
goes off the rails with everything and i
understand that the show does a fair
amount of other stuff and people say oh
it's better but like it's still based
off his work and
i'm not interested
lucy wood uh thank you kindly
hi council of geeks will you do a
re-ranking of the doctors once the
centenary special comes out lucy
spoilers
yes i am planning on doing that
yeah you caught me
oh let's see here
that's not what it i say it's water
don't call me a liar
are the billionaires being murdered in
the streets one of the things that td
uh k are that age poorly most people
would
now will probably support that sort of
thing
i mean
i think the part of that that stage
poorly is the idea that the billionaires
would ever put them in a put themselves
in a position where they could be picked
off on the street
but yeah it's it's hard to see that as a
bad thing at this point
uh
it's a free-for-all around here no mask
yeah i know meg like i i still wear
masks like when i go to
when i go grocery shopping or into or to
the post office or whatever but yeah
nobody else does thankfully nobody gives
me crap for wearing one it's not that
kind of area but yeah
nobody has the damn thing
stephen schwartz wrote the songs for
pocahontas the hunchback of notre dame
and prince of persia and wicked oh
ha
then i kind of wonder if he's a little
too seriously minded for owl house i
feel like
honestly i feel like getting the guys um
from
[Music]
starkid might be a better fit
tone wise for um
for owl house
let's see
there is actually a spanish-language
version of dracula that was filmed at
the same time on the same sets uh as the
lugosi one and most people now consider
that the superior film i have heard that
i have not seen it but i have heard that
taikawat tt should make howard the duck
that would work
do you have a favorite auteur director
if so who and why i think right now it's
probably guillermo del toro
like he he just does something that i
love that not a lot of people do which
is to take
horror aesthetics
but
um
tell something other than horror stories
with them which i appreciate
uh want to hear something funny at first
i wonder
uh
if you present as male or female when
you reviewed accession because queer
content um but it took you so long you
fully transitioned in the interim
oh that's true because you commissioned
me to read that book way back when i i
used to delineate fairly
strongly between presenting masculine
and feminine but by the time i finished
reading the damn thing and did the
review i was just presenting as like my
queer self
all the time
oh boy
talking about the boys and similar
things thought on the opinion that we
need more hopeful less dark uh and even
silly superhero stuff again not in the
cynical sense i mean i generally agree
with that i i don't think
i'm not gonna say there's no place or no
need for the darker more cynical stuff
and there's clearly a market for it and
for some people that's kind of what they
need but like
hold on
that's part of why i still love the mcu
um is that it largely retains
at least one foot in the lighter tone
which i know is what some people don't
like about it um but for me i kind of
need that
what's the seinfeld effect i'm not sure
i actually understand what it is i
suspect i do i don't think i'm going to
be able to
uh explain that for you
if it was entirely up to you which
doctors would you want back for the 60th
do i personally think mcgann
would be great with tenant would love to
see classics involved um
well okay
we've already had
tom baker come back not to say that he
couldn't again but like i feel like that
that work the curator works is a really
good final appearance for him
so
honestly kind of all the rest of them
davison colin baker
mccoy mcgann
bring all the classic ones in
i don't know what you do with them
but
that's that's what i'm inclined to say
discord yes um yeah give me
one
second
any slice of life or utopia kind of
stories to recommend i'm very much in a
mood for light stories
not off the top of my head
although okay
i'm gonna make a recommendation that is
bizarre i'm gonna recommend a
uh episode of black mirror to you not
the show as a whole but just the episode
san junipero if you haven't seen that
give that a look all right i gotta pop
over to the discord for the council of
geeks patreon and see what questions
were brought up there back in a few
minutes
uh live stream questions uh from someone
possibly sleeping
how many house of dragons questions have
there been so far just a couple uh if
none
uh if none are you going to review the
episodes definitely the first one we'll
see what i feel after that
uh ask someone who bailed on game of
thrones in the final season uh uh as why
watching something that's increasingly
actively annoying you like i stuck
through it because i thought well it's
almost over how many affleck is coming
back questions have there been so far do
we care actually that has not come up is
that in the rumor mill again
that keeps cycling back around every few
months
answer me these questions three which
other medium would you like to see
dreams of fire on and why
i would be interested if someone ever
wanted to take a crack at a comic book
adaptation um
i think
the world could suit a tv series i think
the story is too low key for film
considering how expensive it would be to
shoot if folks don't know that's my own
fantasy novel that we're talking about
which x-men character is overrated and
why is it cyclops i don't think cyclops
is overrated nobody likes cyclops that's
the joke everybody hates him
i don't think you can call the character
that everybody hates overrated i don't
think that works
uh honestly uh professor x is because
the character has been a mess for the
last few decades if money was no
obstacle would you still create content
yes i love doing this
absolutely
i'd create bigger
and
more elaborate content if money was no
object
okay one question i saw someone say that
nobody will win the streaming wars do
you agree because i sort of do um
yeah short version yes so
the thing is it took a lot longer for
things to level out than i would have
expected but
we went through the period initially i'm
gonna try and do a short version of this
we went through a period initially where
netflix just got bigger and bigger and
bigger bigger because netflix became the
one stop shop
and you know they just kept expanding
and getting more loans just throwing
money at it and just kept going
but
eventually while they could have gotten
bigger then everybody else came in with
their own streaming services and the
potential audience pool started getting
divided up and the content started
getting divided up and now it became a
question of what one has what content i
want and they can't all grow the way
netflix did at first because the reason
netflix grew the way it did it first is
because for a while it was basically the
only game in town and it could throw
money at the problem basically non-stop
because its growth potential was so huge
at this point there was a much harder
ceiling on how big any of these can get
and as we're seeing now with hbo max
which honestly what's happening with hbo
max is screwed up in a lot of ways but
what is happening is a much harsher
version of what's gonna have to start
happening with everything else you spend
a ton of money at the front end to build
it up as big as you can but then you
have to start trimming because the
growth is not exponential on the
platform so yeah the the whole thing is
going to throttle itself after a while
and settle into something not nearly as
exciting
oh what is your favorite what was your
favorite part of your holiday that
you're willing to share with us honestly
i just kind of liked that liz and i got
to
share
something nostalgic for each of us with
the other
so we went to massachusetts we went to
cape cod and on the way down we stopped
at wellesley
um which is uh that college's uh liz's
alma mater that she went to undergrad
there and
it was she really loved being able to
take me around the campus
show me some of the stuff tell me about
you know what it was like living there
and then we got to provincetown on the
cape and i got to show around and tell
her about you know how this was a place
that i always
um you know went with my family uh the
day after thanksgiving we always used to
go for the day i got to point out to her
you know what shops were still there
uh the candy store where my family
always got fudge is still there i did
buy some fudge um
or like point out some things that used
to be something else like the restaurant
we used to go to isn't there anymore i'm
like that used to be it and i think it
was nice for us to both
kind of share something of our own
history with each other
i think was the nicest thing about it
have you watched heart stopper i have
not i have not had the time
um nor the inclination as yet like i'm
sure it's i don't doubt that it's good
i've just got so much other crap to do
uh what do you okay so these are the
questions regarding the culture which is
a book series that i have done reviews
on two of the books so far
and i'm working on a third one so let me
try and get through these
what do you think of the culture sort of
justice system as described in service
detail i mean the mind telling le deja
if she has a problem with its choice
uh to slap drone her she'd have to call
for a direct democratic vote to overrule
the idea the culture has some
anarchist elements and resolving
disputes by direct democracy is meant to
be part of that i think it's an
interesting way it's an interesting
outgrowth
for a society that has basically given
over the vast majority of its decisions
to machines
um and and actually had that work out
well for them which is also just
inherently one of the things i find
really interesting about the culture
both the book series and the
society because generally you know
people give their uh decision making
over to machines is almo is almost
always a dystopia or then the robot
operator or whatever but like it really
actually worked out incredibly well for
them so
like
that that
notion and sort of the work around it
it's just i just find a lot of it
interesting i don't know like if i'd
ever use how much if any of it i'd ever
use as a model for what a society should
be or whether i call any of it utopian
but i find it all fascinating
there's an interview with banks that's
the author somewhere on youtube where he
said he believed if people had the power
to change sex at will that would promote
gender equality because otherwise you'd
end up with too many people opting to be
the gender that has the most privilege
does the fact that he believed
uh that show as progressive as he was he
didn't understand how gender identity
actually works i'm
yes it does show that from his position
as a cisgender man he did not
understand that
many people feel a very strong draw to
be something specific most cis people
don't get that and it's not because they
don't strongly identify with their own
identity as a cisgender man or woman but
because they haven't had to move
they haven't had to shift to be who they
are so they don't really appreciate that
that having been said as with a lot of
stuff related to the culture i do think
that the whole thing is far enough in
the future that it's
an argument could be made that once it
gets ingrained in a society for long
enough
that gender is changeable at a whim and
at a wish
gender and sex for that matter because
of the technology that they have
that a lot of those differences would
fade away
um but
i i i because you know as i've said
before not all trans people have massive
dysphoria and so dysphoria and a need to
be this thing is not the only thing that
drives people
but yeah his his
thought process is very
detached and intellectual about
something that is for trans people
especially deeply personal and emotional
but you know he meant well
uh the hell parts of surface detail
for you does the fact that the uh
pavilions are non-humanoid i think
they're meant uh to like
to be like two tiny trunked elephants
make the description of the horrible
happening to them less disturbing than
if they did look humans no because the
thing is my brain still plugs in humans
um and i don't know if that's a standard
reader um
thing but like it it it the same thing
happens happens to me um whenever i
reread um
hitchhiker's guides at the galaxy i keep
forgetting zaphod has two heads when i
picture him in my mind i forget that he
has two heads until the book
specifically mentions it my brain
plugs in the standard template and so
with the pavooliens i
frequently forget that they are
quadrupedal with two trunks as you know
working
similar to how we would use our arms
until something in the actual writing
mentions it so
the thing is i actually pictured the
hell sequences with people because my
brain wouldn't plug in the alien shapes
again i don't know if that's typical if
that's just my brain anyway
i'm back to i'm back to the main chat i
am out of the uh out of the discord i
see we have some super chats
all right
supreme omega thank you very much i'm
surprised there are not much adaptations
of
on married spider-man the marriage
existed for 20 years and there were
classic stories in that era
there's two reasons for that if i were
to guess the first is
for some
goddamn reason every single continuity
of spider-man
feels the need to start with his origin
which means they have all
all given us at least initially a
teenage peter boy am i sick of it and i
love tom holland i think he's great in
the park but i'm so done so done
with teenage spiderman i'm like i'm so
done with it
and part of that has to also do with the
fact that when i actually
read
um
spider-man in the comics i read him in
the 90s he was in his 30s married
so like i want to see that but we never
freaking get it
so
but the other even aside from the fact
that they keep redoing the damn origin
and so did every tv show for that matter
spider-man spectacular spider-man
amazing spider-man like all the tv shows
started with him as a freaking teenager
too yeah
oh
the the
the corporates have decided
that part of the appeal of spider-man is
that he's a teenage superhero now that
is absolutely true of part of his
original appeal
in the comics because it was unique at
the time and certainly the people who
first read that at the time that they
all say they lashed onto that but he was
a teenager
for like
five six years
then was in college then he's been in a
he has been an adult in the comics for
so long okay but that's only the one
reason the other is for some idiotic
reason writers hated mary jane
or at least hated the fact that they
were married
and marvel collectively seemed to hate
it
and
it's
and a lot of specific writers seem to
hate it and it's dumb and you can have a
superhero in a stable relationship he
did it he made it work it was great and
i'm still but i'm still
i'm still pissed
about one more day
funny you mentioned hitchhiker's god i
was thinking that oh good see someone's
on the same page
uh does plugin humans
by default apply to stuff with regular
animal protagonists like watership down
or red raptor or just alien stuff pretty
much just alien stuff uh stephen because
like
the way that
the characters and something like the
culture books
um
they the way that they talk and interact
and intellectualize is all very human
for the most part and so my brain plugs
in human because i don't have a direct
frame of reference for what they
actually are whereas a half frame of
reference for
you know rabbits and watership down or
or uh or anything like that so yeah
that's not an issue with the animal
stuff
really just with the with the alien
stuff
plot twist peter parker is actually
stuck in a time loop as soon as he
graduates high school he starts high
school over again oh god he's in hell
uh have you ever watched z nation from
what i understand it's a zombie film
that doesn't take itself too seriously
it's kind of ridiculous think you'd
enjoy it i have not i'm kind of burnt
out on zombies if i'm going to be
completely honest i say that as someone
who has like a
zombie concept half written
everyone's still freaking out of the
60th teasers while i'm speculating on
what the 14th doctor's opening line will
be and what the new change to his body
he'll comment on
like i
i think people are freaking out with the
60th because it's what we actually have
a basis for
but yeah we'll we'll see what happens
the joke i made earlier if you did do
the review pre
um
pre-transition what would you have done
my guess was you'd have let your hair
down specifically when you got to the
gender bender given how i was
handling that kind of material on video
at the time
yeah that that's probably correct how
was the beach the beach was great uh the
goji shea
um it was quite nice i you know i hadn't
realized
um how much i missed
the beach
like the ocean beach like i've been to
beaches we have lakes
um but i hadn't been to an ocean beach
in a long long time i hadn't been to a
beach on cape cod in forever and one of
the things that's really cool
about cape cod is because of the way
the cape curls around
it's one of the few places on the east
coast where you can be on a beach
and
see the
sun setting over the ocean because
normally you gotta be on the west coast
for that
but because of the way
the cape curls around you can actually
watch the sunset into the ocean
from new england which is very cool and
i'd kind of forgotten that
it was nice it was really nice
stuff i stuff i
was overdue to do did you like this
hitchhiker's guide movie no
no
it's part of the reason i don't like sam
rockwell
are you excited for miguel o'hara and
the spider-verse i'm excited and nervous
because
he is my favorite spider-man
which means i really wanted to be done
well because he ha he we have gotten so
little of him
huh so just just don't blow it
just don't blow it please like i like
oscar isaac is a real good voice pick
so there is that
um
oh john vinyls i missed i missed one of
your super chats i'm sorry um in some
ways owl house is kind of del toro vibe
um to be quite honest yeah a little bit
a little bit brighter but yeah not not a
million miles off
um and lucy wood we are going to wrap it
up soon um so let's see
excuse me lucy uh hi do you think that
doctor who will do series 14 in early
2023
no
no i expect we will get series 14 proper
in 2024
because i do not expect series 14 to air
ahead of the 60th anniversary special
and if they hold for the actual proper
60th anniversary that means november of
2023 so
earliest would be immediately following
that i am not expecting us to get series
14 until 2024
[Music]
sorry if you got asked this a thousand
times already but i only started
watching it when it came to disney plus
do you watch the orville i don't
i saw like the first four or five
episodes of the first season like it was
fine but then i just had
other stuff to do
apparently they hated okay so this is
about spider-man marriage apparently
they hated cutting to mary jane worries
about peter parker and couldn't figure
out what to do with her other than that
despite there being a ton you can do
with her other than that right
like if you're sick of writing cut to
mary jane worrying about her then stop
having her worry about him all the damn
time do something just write something
else
you're a writer
think of something
god do i hate that nonsense
it's right up there when people say well
batman can never be in a relationship
because he would not be able to keep
being batman just write it so he does
says who
just write it
like sometimes some things you can't
write because it breaks the character i
refuse to believe that that breaks the
character that's such nonsense
writers especially male writers have
such an aversion to writing happy stable
couples especially in superhero media
it's
freaking exhausting
uh re-watched your dark crystal video
the other day your impression of jen
when the
when the gartham soldiers bursting
killed me i don't even remember what i
did but i'll take your word for it
uh overdue review of the beach yeah a
little bit
um
you never said what you think of lucy's
new ponytail
i didn't even notice
i'm not someone who notices hairstyles
like like very sincerely it's a good
thing that most tv shows when a
character gets a haircut like other
characters go oh hey you got a haircut
because i probably wouldn't notice
otherwise
uh don't know if you've been asked this
have you read anything from the scp
foundation wiki i have not i know what
it is
but no i haven't
um should an alternative colin baker
come in to do a worthy regeneration
story do you think that would work um
i i think it's better just to move on
that's one of those things where i'm
like trying to fix the problem i think
you're better just
ignoring it moving forward rather than
trying to back up
and um and fix it anyways yes thank you
for the reminder caro and twitch
tomorrow i will be what will i be
playing what do i bought i got something
today what the hell did i get
um
i'm trying to remember
what the hell i'm even
streaming
uh
what the hell was it shoot
um
owl boy
there we go i'm playing owlboy on twitch
tomorrow 10 30 uh eastern daylight
time on friday i'll be playing more of
that most likely again on twitch um
i should have tomorrow at some point up
in the break room a review of the first
episode of
house of the dragon and thursday will be
review again in the break room of the
new episode for she-hulk and saturday is
my uh thoughts on the sandman uh show on
netflix it ended up being a main channel
video because i had a lot more thoughts
than would just be in a normal rambling
review so that's what's up for the week
i think that's everything
uh
hmm i think that's everything
does it make a difference uh how alien
the aliens are like the uh
the pavilions just look like small
elephants
not giant
uh balloon octopus things like the front
oddly enough the affront is one of the
few aliens that i can think of that i
did
um i was able to picture the alien
version i think it was because like
their behavior
felt less approximate to humans so like
their behavior also felt a little bit
more alien so i think that might have
helped me plug in uh something closer to
how they were actually supposed to look
you notice amity's new purple hair right
that i noticed yes that i did notice all
right trying to wrap it up
um
thank you all for joining me
thank you for
being here for the questions for the
super chats for
just chilling for a bit
that's good water
so i hope that you have a good rest of
the week
i hope that you will
um tune in for some of the other stuff
that i've got going on
that um that i talked about
and i hope that you
remember that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned